so we were looking through bust magazine
online how bust magazine yes and you
recorded as saying they call it the
glass ceiling but I call it the brick
wall in terms of being a female
filmmaker so what do you think are some
of the things that make it tougher for
women and what are some of the things
that we can do to break down those
barriers or maybe we're not there yet
well the thing that makes it really
tough is that you don't get a chance to
be part of the club you know every
business has its club that nurtures new
young people who come in and somebody
wants to pass on the knowledge well
nobody wants to pass it on to a girl in
the movie business they just don't if
you're not part of the club and if
you're not part of the club it's very
hard to learn your craft and it's hard
to be an insider and it's hard to get to
the place where you can even get a
chance to prove yourself as a director
so that's why I call it a brick wall
because they're there is very limited
resources now that's not to say they're
not they don't exist because as you can
see some women are really breaking
through in big ways but generally unless
you have some kind of special in you're
not going to get there just by being
good or being talented or doing
everything right it's just not there for
you so that's the brick wall and I think
if you look at it as a brick wall and
you say well I'm gonna stop butting my
head against this brick wall and I'm
going to find another way to do this
that's where you go out and you find
some other way and for me doing
documentaries is the other way to do it
or to do any of the other things that I
do like I direct in theatre and you know
wherever else that I possibly can and
that's that's my answer for myself I
think everybody has to find their own
answer but that's what I've found you
said you think the
maybe it's a system designed to make one
fail well yeah you know I i really take
that from the comment that Amy Pascal
made in the news the other day or that
she was quoted as saying that the system
is set up for women to fail and that's
because that same thing there is no
process by which you can automatically
move up the ladder and that isn't to say
that it's not hard it's hard for men to
move up the ladder to but if you feel
that you're a really gifted filmmaker
and that that's what you're meant to do
in life then there should be ways for
you to pursue that and when you get out
there and you don't find any ways open
to you that's that's where the system is
is set up for you to fail free me I
remember we have a conversation at a
time talking about the article I didn't
mean to Forza your mouth we were
discussing that how do you think that
the system is designed for women to fail
in terms of what Amy's other kids well
even if you get a shot at it and you
don't have the support that you need in
order to be successful then the chances
of failure are pretty big and especially
if you come onto a set where everyone's
hostile to you you know I couldn't used
to believe that that was gonna happen I
used to think what you know I'm a really
good person to work for people love to
work with me I can get out of set and
you know everything I'll make everybody
feel good and will all work well
together well the first time that I came
on to a set of a commercial television
show I found enormous hostility
hostility by men on the crew who wanted
to do what I was doing and they had been
laboring on this particular show for two
years three years and who is this chick
coming in who is doing the job that I
don't get to do and a lot of
undermining went on and that was a bit
of a shock to me so the set up to fail
exists out there notice that whenever
you do encounter hostility whatever feel
that's it it's usually because somebody
wants to be right where you are exactly
and that's an interesting lesson there's
a select few of women that are allowed
in what do you think the difference well
you know everybody has their own path in
life and some of the women that I know
who our successful have come up through
the inside of the business come up as
script supervisors and in that way
they've built a community from within
that has supported them which is that's
a wonderful way to come in others have
been producers and have come in that way
and you know maybe somebody has done
some remarkable bit of work in the
theater that has brought them to the
attention of some major director who has
been willing to help them or has been an
assistant to a major director and I
think that in those instances there has
been a man there who has been willing to
say yes I will help this woman in but
without that without that kind of Mentor
in the business it's it's pretty
difficult do you think that's what
interests you so much in hearing about
these female jazz musicians as some of
the parallels I realize it was a
different time then racism played a huge
part in their lives at that point it
still doesn't sure but do you think
that's where you really felt a kinship I
did feel a kinship with them I felt that
they were going through exactly what I
was going through so it was when I saw
that I said hey this is not just my
story or the women's musicians story
this is the woman's story this is our
story and I think that one of the things
that I would like to do is encourage
women to make up their own world you
know we have to hold up our end of the
world and we have to create a world in
which we work and in which we feel
comfortable and there are a lot of men
who are willing to support us I've had
the support of many wonderful men on
this project but it's because we are
telling our story and our story needs to
be told the world is not about
and we got to help get it in balance